I am starting a series called Arranging Advent
where we are arranging our lives just in time for advent season.
Advent season is meant to be joyful,
but often we find ourselves stressed and worn out.
Prepping ahead of time can take a lot of that stress away.
October is when I start putting my plans for advent into motion.
Start by writing out the different sections
that make sense for your family.
For us that's electrical, lifting, gifts,
baking, etc.
I go through all of my books.
I love Suma Domestica. Cannot recommend her books enough.
Also pull out all my cookbooks of baking ideas I wanna use
as well as homemade gift recipes.